- Cabin porn, I found cabin porn.
People who come here really love cabins.
This is, well, I'm gonna
go look at some cabin porn.
- So I just learned of these
things called getaway cabins.
There's a company that
markets toward people
that live in the city that just need
to disconnect in the middle of the woods.
I'm an introvert, so
I thought I would love
to do something like this,
but then I thought it
might make a more
interesting video to have
somebody that's an extrovert
do this by themself.
So, I'm gonna bring my coworker,
Eric, who's always talking,
he's always on his phone,
he's always talking
about social media and
his Instagram followers.
- I really wanna get
more Instagram followers,
so why don't you guys follow me?
- I thought, if anybody,
he could benefit from something like this.
I'm not gonna tell him
that he's by himself
because I don't think he would come.
- All right, guys, so I'm
super excited about this video.
I'm about to go on some
sort of like vacation.
I'll get to know Christian,
he seems like a cool guy,
he's talented, he's very serious.
I don't think he likes me very much,
so I'm surprised he asked me to come.
He randomly came up to me, asked me
to come to the woods with him.
I'm starting to think this, I'm sure
it'll be fine, it'll be great.
I'm going to the woods with
Christian, let's do it.
(inspirational orchestra music)
- [Christian] So, I told you that
this was about like us like disconnecting.
- Us disconnecting and
connecting with each other.
- So, the first part of that is true,
we're gonna be disconnecting.
I'm gonna be no where near
you during this video.
Like we are staying in
cabins, but we have two
separate cabins, very
far away from each other
in the middle of this
big piece of property.
We're gonna have no contact the entire
time with each other or anybody else.
- What if I get sick, what if I
get sick, and I need to call somebody?
I have a Jewish mom,
what is, how am I going
to contact my Jewish mom
to tell her that I'm okay?
Hey, Mom ...
- [Mom] Yeah?
- I'm not gonna be able to communicate
with you for the next 24 hours.
- [Mom] 24 hours, okay,
baby, okay, I got it.
- Well, she didn't seem to really care.
I want everybody to know I'm
not happy about this situation.
I'm basically being kidnapped.
- These next 24 hours,
you are gonna have to
first, get over the fact that you
don't have a cell phone
that you can be on.
There's no social media,
what goes on in your brain
when you don't have any distractions,
that's gonna be the
cool part of this video.
- Nothing!
- No, we're not--
- Nothing goes on in my brain.
- But something's gonna
go on in your brain.
You're gonna get to a place where
you're gonna be thinking
beyond the obvious.
I'm sure right now when you're bored,
the first thing you do
is you pick up your phone
and look to see like
has anybody emailed me,
has anybody texted me, are there any cool
Instagram photos I haven't seen yet?
You're gonna be out in the woods,
and when you get to that first level
of boredom, something
else is gonna happen.
You're gonna have to make a decision
to do something, or you're
just gonna be sitting down
and like your mind's
gonna start wandering.
Your creative mind, like what can you
create in those moments
when there's no noise?
- You're really good at selling what
you're selling right
now, but I still predict
I'm going to hate the next 24 hours.
Jesus!
(trombone thunders)
This looks terrifying on
camera and in real life.
(laughing)
Okay, please don't leave me, can we just,
can we change the frame of the
video and we just stay together?
- No.
- Please.
- Oh, fuck it, my service is gone.
I'm gonna be so lonely.
- Get out.
- No.
- This is it.
- You're leaving me?
- Yep.
- I just have to walk outta here?
- Yeah, just grab your shit.
- All right, I guess this is goodbye.
- See ya tomorrow.
Nope.
- This is gonna be a
long 24 hours, oh my God.
Well, I'm in the woods
alone, I have no idea
where Christian is,
let's see what happens.
Okay, so there's this little like,
you don't even use keys here.
It's a little code, which I don't trust
cause there's only six, bet you any killer
who comes here could just
figure out what my code is.
(loud inhale)
Smells like wood, Jesus, oh my God!
The bed is right by a massive window.
I'm freaking out, I
know I'm gonna wake up,
and I'm gonna open my
eyes, and there's gonna be
some creepy dude standing
right by the window.
Jesus, that's a lot of knives.
I need to get rid of these knives.
They have this, you know where
you see these kinds of things.
You see these kinds of lights,
you see them in horror movies,
that's the only time you ever
see these kind of lights.
Nobody uses these lights.
What the hell is alien toilet?
(plastic crinkles loudly)
(industrial hair dryer-type air noises)
What just happened?
And the food, they got some good food.
I'm not complain about that,
they got some porridge,
they got some good stuff.
Look, it's a cool place, but I'm scared.
I'm very, very, very,
very, very, very scared.
I've nothing to do.
- All right so I just dropped off Eric
at his cabin, and this is mine.
Oooh, I love everything about this.
I can get used to this.
I have to imagine that
Eric is loving this.
(trombone thunders)
- It's so quiet here, I'm like really
not used to it, it's really eerie.
Literally, listen.
(birds singing)
(lively symphony music)
So, they gave me this little book,
Now What, for people like me that will
kinda help you if it's your first time
being alone, and you don't know what to do
and how to be without your cell phone.
Begin by writing out commitment,
something you would like to remember
when returning to civilization.
Take you time thinking about it,
the deeper into your getaway you are,
the clearer you'll see
what needs to be done.
So, it's time to get to writing.
(clock ticking)
(lively symphony music)
(fire crackling)
- It's kinda nice to not
have anything to worry about.
I mean, how often do you get to just
look into a fire and not have
to do or think about anything.
There is a part of me that is starting
to worry about Eric though.
- So I just spent 30 minutes just
writing everything and not gonna tell ya
what I wrote cause that was more for me.
I'm surprised I feel
very relaxed right now.
Felt really good just
writing everything out.
I didn't think that one
activity would just like change
my perspective on this
experience so quickly,
but I'm really ready to just
embrace this whole thing now.
Next thing this book talks
about, forest bathing,
and they recommend that you walk around
the forest, and I'm gonna go for a walk.
(trombone thunders)
Guys, it got darker, guys,
I have no idea where I am.
I was walking, and then
it started to get dark ...
What the fuck was that?
Sorry, I keep hearing stuff, the fuck?
I literally cannot see past like
a foot in front of me, look.
I've been walking for about two hours now,
and I have no idea where
to go or where I am.
All right, well, I'm gonna go,
I'm just gonna keep walking
and hopefully I can find my cabin.
(rooster crows)
- I just woke up, to wake
up to this is pretty cool.
All right, so, I'm gonna
go out, just check on Eric.
All right, here he is.
(knocking on glass)
(knocking on metal)
Don't see him.
Okay, have no service,
it's not even ringing.
I'm gonna go back to my cabin,
see if maybe he just like
went out looking for me.
If not, there is a trail
that's not too far away.
I might take a walk down
just to see if he's there.
(water roaring)
I have no idea where he is.
(person howling in the distance)
I can hear him.
(person yelling in the distance)
- Whoooooooo!
(tape rewind screeching)
Oh, I found it, it was like 20 feet away.
So, I made it back to the cabin.
Just woke up, and I actually feel amazing,
and then I just woke up to nature.
I think I'm just gonna go for a hike.
It's so pretty I wish, you
guys can't even experience
like what it smells like, how pretty,
I mean, if you've been to
a forest then you know.
It's amazing, I'm alone
right now with my thoughts.
There's no one else
here, this feels so great
just the loud noise, the
loud sounds of water.
This feels amazing, this
trip was 100% worth it.
I'm just here thinking, I feel
so happy, I feel incredible.
Ahhh-la-la-la-la-la ooooh!
Christian!
I've missed you!
- How d'ya feel?
- I feel amazing, Christian.
I feel like I'm so relaxed,
I'm not worried about anything.
I've got no stress, I
haven't checked my phone
once this entire time, I
haven't checked my Instagram.
I might've lost all my
followers, but I don't even care.
- Insert drone shot.
(laughing)
We don't have a drone.
- We don't have a drone.
(laughing)
It's time to go, I
really don't wanna leave.
I've had an incredible
time, this was awesome.
Thank you, Christian.
Everyone should try being in silence,
get bored, be lonely, good
things will come from that.
Whoo, whoo, ahhhh, pine
cones up my ass right now.
(trombone thunders)